joining us right now is the hall of
famer marshall faulk i feel like i'm
living a dream playing the guys for my
video games uh now i'm getting a chance
to talk with them it's ridiculous how
are you marshall
doing good man doing good how's it going
with you guys doing well we appreciate
you taking some time and and uh i i want
to start with just the festivities over
the weekend out in canton the joy for us
to watch some of our favorite players
get inducted but what was it like for
you to be there and to see these guys up
close
oh man it was awesome you know uh and i
think what what made it even
more special was the fact that last
the last last year we didn't get to have
one
and um i mean it was a it was a big one
too you know we missed a big one
continue to class centennial class we
had 20 guys go in
um and you saw saturday those guys were
recognized
uh and then uh sunday you know we got
the class of 2021 to go in
but um anytime we can get together and
we get you know we get in the room and
uh the stories start flowing um uh just
the information
uh the how and whys and uh you know it's
it's it's just it's just great to be in
that room
um i just look back and i i think about
the guys
that i grew up watching and the guys
before that that i watch film on and i
think man it's awesome
it's just awesome that
that i get to be in this room with the
pillars of the nfl
were there any of the speeches in
particular that that struck you as a
michigan guy seeing charles woodson sing
boys to men to his mother hit me real
hard how about for you being out there
were there any moments from the speeches
that really grabbed you all of them all
of them man all of those speeches were
impactful
uh and if you you know if you listen to
the messaging
everybody everybody
had
i mean they said in some way
how we as a people
need to find a way to live in this world
and coexist and all
not just get along but but thrive along
and that's what that's what that's what
everybody's message
um after they said their thank yous and
and and uh
you know the people who helped them get
there and all of that stuff
their message was pretty much the same
and it shows that
a lot of reflecting went
went into
them giving their speeches and and what
happened in 2020 and all the stuff that
we
were going through in our country
um
that together we're better
well said marshall marshall falk joining
the show ben lyons in for rich on the
rich eisen show as we embark on this new
season a big story line obviously
marshall is vaccinations and which
players are getting the vaccine which
ones remain unvaccinated i know this is
an issue you're very passionate about
and you're doing some work with the
legends committee to inspire people to
go out there and get vaccinated what can
you say about the work you're up to
right now
well the work that the work that i'm
doing is just allowing people to give
for us to give each other space
if i choose to be vaccinated let me
choose to be vaccinated if someone else
chooses not to be vaccinated let them
choose not to be vaccinated
the beauty is in the education
and explaining to people who may not be
um what's at risk and the people who
decide to be what's at risk because i
think sometimes we we all just want to
be in the same little bubble at the same
time that's not going to ever happen
individuals will be individuals and uh
if you think about our great country you
know it's the fact that you get to be an
individual here
and so so we have to just find the space
to allow
uh people to make the decisions and i
think what we're doing
and what i'm doing on this is is saying
hey listen um
don't listen to the the the lies and the
falsehoods that's going around social
media
i'm a person who have i have a lot to
lose and hey i got vaccinated because i
want to be responsible
um as a person whom i was at the hall of
fame there's a lot of people walking
around they want to fist bump they want
to hug they want to do stuff and and
if there's a level of responsibility
that i can say i've taken that step
that's what i want to do i want to be
responsible
marshall oftentimes retired players will
think about the game today and which
players they would love to compete
against or compete alongside
obviously
you never faced anything like this while
you were playing in the nfl do you think
back what those conversations might have
been like with teammates in the locker
room or on the planes when it comes to
getting vaccinated and living in this
coveted world that we now are in
well you know what um
i'ma tell you it wasn't it wasn't like
this
but
the
do we play
and do we get on the plane is it safe do
we travel after 9 11. that was a big
deal
that was a big deal
and um you know we had so many team
meetings the league was wondering do we
continue to play and what's the best
decision
and and i think i think
even in that
sense
making the best decision collectively
it's always the better
choice
and and here's the thing everybody's not
going to be on board
that's the that's the reality of it it's
impossible for everybody to be on board
but um
once again i'm always go back to this
for the people who
who decide
that they want to do
whatever opposite is of what the
majority are doing allow them the space
to do that
just educate them on so they understand
where they're at
that's what this whole campaign is
that's what it is
marshall faulk amongst the nfl alumni
speaking up to encourage people to get
coven 19 vaccinations ben lyons in for
rich on the rich eisen show
getting back to the festivities out in
canton ohio you mentioned being around
so many people is there anybody that you
see in particular that just warms your
heart or gets you star struck or brings
a smile to your face that you see off
stage not necessarily one of the the
inductees but just somebody you run into
that always warms your heart
oh man um you know
when you walk around the museum and and
the people that pridefully work there
that lived there uh you know they
that they're proud that they they've
only lived in canton
and here's here's what i'm gonna say
this here's the best feeling ever
your hall of famer and you walk around
there
every person that live in that town
there they embrace you with this welcome
home
welcome home
and that's such a good feeling
that's such a good feeling um
most of us in life we just want to be
remembered
but when you realize that there's a
museum with my likeness
and what i do
and what i had done in the game of
football my family's family family
they're gonna always be able to go
connect
and show their kids kids my great great
ground on how many greats you want to go
back
i'm there
and i'll tell you something that's
interesting that uh that so uh they
built this thing called centennial
circle downtown and um there's a couple
of establishments around that one
establishment uh specifically is jersey
sports bar um
the the owner of it what he did was he
took it a step further if you play the
down in the nfl
at his restaurant there's a wall where
you can go and find
whoever that person is
whatever year whatever year
you
came into the nfl played it down
you're on that wall one i'm i'm talking
a cup of tea i'm talking about a play
wow you're on that wall
and that that's taking me beyond the
hall of fame
you know and i just think it's it's
awesome man because we all just want to
connect and we want to relate
and that's what this that's what that's
what that week does for all of us
and it was it was much needed after last
year
marshall we saw some of the amazing
busts uh we talked about it i'm
wondering what you thought who had the
best
hair on their bust was it edge was it
drew pearson's
afro troy palamalu who had the best hair
bust that you saw over the weekend you
know i'ma actually go allen fannika oh
yeah just check it out because if you
you look at him now
and you look at him then it's like wow
he's a whole different person he's that
he's he's half the man he once was yeah
doesn't he run marathons and stuff now
or does it try yeah
yeah yeah yeah he really
uh it was just it was like and listen
man jimmy jimmy johnson's too jimmy
johnson's hair doesn't even move
you you don't understand i'm all about
the offense alignment
i'm all about the offensive lineman
literally we're we're sitting in the
rainishkey luncheon and um i sat down at
the table at all offensive linemen
[Laughter]
orlando
face probably was at your table right
yeah yeah pace was at my table uh
zimmerman like daniels
walter
and uh and uh orlando yeah
yeah it was uh
yeah how great was it to see isaac get
his due over the weekend oh man man i
you know
as a as a as a grown man i cried for him
because i know i know what it means to
him i know that mentioned me and i know
the work that he put in to get there and
what he what he had to go through
man that was just um
it was awesome
can we talk about kurt's beard what's
going on with that
uh i asked him about it i was like
what's going in there
just laziness
that's all i got for him
marcia fox joining the show sharing some
memories from that historic day out in
canton ohio over the weekend not the
first time marshall you've had a front
row seat to some historic celebrations
in fact you were in this studio when the
rich eisen show revealed its sign what
do you remember about that historic day
in studio here on the rich eisen show
you know similar and i know you guys are
laughing but you know i was
you know i watched i i watched the radio
show turned into a podcast and then the
podcast become an actual thing and
you know anything that when you're
building a lot goes into it man and i
just know that i know
the the the blood sweat and tears and
energy that rich
and everybody that's there that you know
a lot of the day wonders um what they've
put into it you know uh brockman and and
and del tufo i mean
a lot of work has went into
to what this show
has become and um you know i'm just
proud to have been there i'm proud to be
a part of it and i'm always thankful
when i get a chance to pop on the show
and just just share my insight um on you
know whatever the issue may be uh even
including football
marshall you were here for day two when
we unveiled rich's bust too you and
marcus allen were here
yes i mean listen
everybody doesn't get a bust in life
[Laughter]
that's incredible marshall to see the
growth from this group
uh like uh del tufo can now pull a piece
of cloth with string he can do that now
he's really grown it's incredible
one percent better every day right mike
yeah yes
yeah i mean you know as i'm saying like
the the the group
may not have grown but the fan bases
are still the same
oh good stuff marshall finally do you
put salt on your mcgriddle like jerry
jones we've been talking about that a
lot today
on your mcgregor did you see hard knocks
last night by any chance has marshall
ever had a mcgriddle i'm betting
marshall
yeah that was one of the big clips like
jerry's on the phone trying to figure
out what's going on with dak and he puts
like basically half a thing of salt on
this mcgriddle sandwich
you know i i i mean
wouldn't that because the mcgriddle like
the it's sweet because of the pancake
right the bread right right
so
i would i would only
say that's like um when people put salt
on watermelon
you know it's that sweet salty it's like
a little thing
the only thing i could say
that makes sense yeah but anytime you
turn into a pancake for support you're
kind of already losing i think marshall
um we appreciate you taking some time
thanks for hanging out with us for a
little bit
thank you guys appreciate it
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here